here's a good email from allison she
writes i've been seeing a therapist
since march of 2020
i don't know if she's making an impact
on my life as of today
i feel like i'm paying for a chat with a
girlfriend yikes
what makes a good therapist are there
specific things that should be going on
during a typical session all right so
i'm gonna back that out and here's a
couple of things here
number one well let's just answer the
directly a good therapist
is not your friend they are not your
friend
they are a teacher they are someone who
is walking alongside you right
so a therapist is not your friend they
should not be
be condescending or unrelatable and they
should rarely
rarely give you advice that's not their
job
their job is to hold a mirror up their
job is to
say you say this but here's how you're
living
you want to be free but here's how you
spend your money you want to have great
relationships here's how you choose to
fill in the blank right
their job is to listen deeply to reflect
to teach you how to connect the dots
across
relationships and events and
consequences
a therapist is not a mystic or a healer
or predictor of the future right
as i said earlier a therapist is not
your friend
they're not your buddy they're not your
future romantic partner they're not
someone to try to win over
they're someone to be honest with right
their job is to teach you how to be a
good friend or
how to be a good romantic partner
i started seeing a counselor recently uh
here in nashville
and within 45 minutes man i thought we
were gonna get in a fist fight
he said some things like hey here's what
you've told me about xyz
and i looked at him and thought you
better not say that again
and then he smiled and said ah what is
that
is that sadness or anger and i was like
ooh you got me well played
well played homie and we had a good
exchange he's not my friend
right he's just simply reflecting back
to me things that i was saying that i
hadn't put the dots together on and i
put together dots for a living right
a good therapist a good therapist will
challenge you
therapy should be uncomfortable if it's
done right
a counselor should not always be neutral
they should tell you the truth when
you're wrong
that's been a big thing in the
counseling profession you know
never take sides i think that's nonsense
man i really side with terry reel on
this one
sometimes you gotta take sides sometimes
you gotta look at someone and say this
behavior is childish
this behavior is hurting the people you
love this behavior is not getting you
what you said you wanted to get
right it's their job to point you in a
new direction you haven't considered are
challenges you're avoiding right
and as i've said throughout this little
rant here
a good therapist reflects you to
yourself they hold up a mirror they show
you how people experience you
in the world right so here's a good
example
session two session three the counselor
might find themselves getting really
bored
a good counselor will lean in and be
bold and say
the people in your world call you boring
do they experience you as eeyore as kind
of slow
um as like
do they often check their watch or their
phone when you're talking
what they are teaching you is here is
how the world experiences you
right when the therapist feels bored it
might sound harsh right but
when they reflect their experience and
shares the truth gently it's one of the
most loving things they can do for you
because we live in a culture where
people don't tell the truth or when they
do they weaponize it
and they don't say hey i'm struggling to
stay connected with you is this how
other people experience you
have people told you that before no in
the real world they say
girl you're bored you don't want to hang
out or they lie to you as as to why they
don't invite you to things right
if you truly want to develop skills of
connection you got to be able to accept
this honest feedback right
so that's what a therapist does and so
no if you have been allison if you've
been
in therapy since march 2020 and your
therapist
isn't challenging you to work towards
goals that you've established
if they aren't challenging you to see
the world differently to develop
new skills to teach you new ways of
interacting with yourself and other
people
yeah i mean it's time for you to move on
if you leave counseling and think ah i'm
just chatting with my friend
man you are wasting 150 right or
whatever it costs
right 5 000 or 50 or whatever it happens
to be and therapist
don't do that don't just take people's
money there's the backlogs are too big
there's too many people who need help if
people are doing well and you're just at
the chatting stage
let them go let them go if you
need to find a therapist ask people you
trust check with your insurance for an
in-network provider think about what
kind of therapist you're going to need
right
you can be more comfortable meeting with
a man or a woman do you want online
telehealth appointments are in person
i'm super biased about in person if at
all possible right
does it do they have to have spiritual
beliefs that you share or worldview
beliefs
does it need to be somebody who
specializes in grief or marriage or
parenting or aging trauma
whatever it is think about what you're
looking for ask people you trust
check with your insurance provider check
online
or look into local resources and there's
everything from
graduate school university programs i
was an intern
right that's and i saw people for free
um i was at a family counseling that had
sliding scale for folks who couldn't
afford
high dollar stuff and then there's cash
pay right if you are blessed and you've
got the money you can pay for cash pay
go get it whatever you need to do and
then ask your potential therapist a few
questions do you accept my insurance
can you help me with my particular
challenges will we commit to this
relationship for a few months or for
longer
and here's a big one don't give up after
the first session
it should be awkward and weird right i
left my first session the other day
fired up
and i can't wait to go back because i
know that challenge is good
it's like going to the gym and getting a
personal trainer and that first session
makes you sore the next day and you're
like i'm never working out again
no you're supposed to right if you
haven't been to the gym in a while it's
supposed to be uncomfortable
supposed to be right so if you are
struggling
and you need somebody please be bold and
brave and
go talk to somebody right go a couple of
sessions before you bail out
and for god's sakes man prepare to be
challenged
it's good it's good to be challenged
it's hard but it's good